the man himself gary kasparov on the
sky call gary welcome welcome welcome hi
thank you very much so i wish we had
more um
uh entertainment in this round
yo i thought i would be at the very end
you know talking about you know
uh as tight finish and uh
sorry yeah
yeah we can talk about chess because the
tournament as we all know is over
and my congratulations technically still
it's just one round to go uh for him to
fix it but congratulations to to to
young for for a very formal performance
i agreed gary i i got this list of
questions here for you
and uh a lot of people on uh uh are got
their questions ready but the first
question i needed to ask you
is gary
regarding the candidates what did you
properly predict about this event
which is you know i thought it's the
yeah i think mistake i made and i think
many others was it's it's
underestimating the preparation that is
normally done for the world championship
match
i i actually i i can kick myself in my
head saying wow how could i make a
mistake don't forget you know the same
effect happened you know i was wishing
when you lost to magnus his first match
and then he won the candidates right
because the amount of work that being
done for the world championship match
you know it could could uh you know
serve as the as a very
viable ammunition for next events and
because the candidates are just almost
the next event so there's so much that
has not been seen on stage of the world
championship match all the ideas and
then just not ideas but this is the the
energy that has been you know um
allocated to fight and you know young
collapsed after game six uh and then he
couldn't recover but there's so much he
saved and and we saw that his total
dominance and again i have to apologize
for being you know
such an idiot not you know
anticipating the the preparation for the
world championship match are you even
forgetting what vishy did uh what eight
years ago right
no i was fantastic you make such a very
very valid point that
nepo invested so much energy and he's
got so much in his arsenal of opening
weapons opening ideas and they could be
used in this candidates so he comes with
a great deal of preparation which
dovetails incredibly nicely with this
idea that magnus is getting tired
of playing these world championship
matches that magnus himself has
made some noises gary we don't know but
he's made some noises that he may not
defend
this world title and then it's the top
two finishers
of this candidate tournament
okay yes i understand you want to make
the end of the tournament more exciting
i'm doing my best
i need your help though
something just to debate and something
to bet on because if
and i think it's a very very very big if
okay because from magnus statement
actually not statements noises that he
may consider
not playing if it's not alireza forugia
that's what he said yeah more or less
right yeah
due to the final decision not to defend
his title
it's a long long long distance yeah so
um
i mean now it's with with nepo as as
99.9 percent his next opponent so it's
um you know let's let's check if magnus
was serious because that's exactly the
situation he meant i mean i'm tired sick
and tired i want something new okay
let's see what happens um but again in
this case you're right we should look
for who's going to be second and uh now
is dink playing so poorly today
and being crushed in less than 25 moves
uh by rajab with black so uh it's you
know it might be quite quite quite a
finish for uh for ding and and uh um
hikaru and um and caruana i guess i
don't know what's happening now yeah but
i think that's those though three that
could uh
could um still win uh win the second
prize which could become you know very
valuable uh
i can't let you escape especially you
gary i can't let you escape
without asking than the salient question
because you played more world
championship
in the modern era more world
championship matches than anybody
and you know yourself
best of all
how much they took out of you how much
time
you invested and i remember you're
saying
that your perpetual opponent karpov that
you had finally
gotten rid of this guy
that you were such a yesterday
yes but let's you know let's not mislead
our our viewers now i played world
championship matches in the 80s and 90s
right the first match was carpool 48
game
then we played 85 86 87 99 24 games each
so we played matt you know uh for
i mean 10 weeks
right that's it's
not counting unlimited match with nigel
short so it was a bit shorter that's
because i won earlier but still it was
it was a long match right yeah and and
the last one i played with with with
kramnik's still 15 games right so um
uh um long matches you know uh schedule
was tighter time control was longer so
yeah you're right it was very exhausting
now they play shorter matches but the
amount of preparation they they do
before the match
is huge now consider computers and and
and how many uh uh um
seconds enough associates are working
with them you are talking about tons of
work you know libraries that are being
created and only you know tiny tiny bit
of that can be used right and um and i
understand that magnus you know you know
using his experience and he played
really you know just okay as many
matches as i did uh um and and modern
matches he probably you know um
succeeded in in cutting um
nepal's preparation to a minimum
so which means that nepal had so much
left in
so many arrows he left in in square
right
uh sorry for dominating the questions
i've got to allow dorsa and alejandro in
on the uh conversations but absolutely
thank you for
uh pointing out those very salient
differences that you were playing 24
game matches but the the the the the
modern uh
uh match preparation is so much greater
creating libraries alejandro dorsa
alejandro well gary i have to ask you
since we are talking about second place
in this tournament of course ding is
getting crushed today but let's talk
about a certain fabiano carona what is
happening do you think in his mind he
starts the tournament like you would
think plus three in the first seven he's
chasing nepo down
five is not the type of person that
collapses half a point out of four in
the last four games what's going on with
him
yeah but i i think that it's you know
one game can have a decisive effect and
i think the game with nepal i mean had a
really bad bad effect on him so um
actually i remember i looked at it at
the game you know when he was thinking
about
moving his bishop you know he should
take c5 for bishop f1
that decisive moment right absolutely
absolutely decisive moment absolute
decisive moment
i don't know what he thought i didn't
hear his comment commentary so but you
know somehow fabi is always not feeling
very comfortable and what all pieces are
hanging and i he tried instinctively
tried to simplify it and and you you
wasted his advantage and i think it had
really bad effect on him another great
effect on nepal so we could see that you
know they they their past you know uh
they they they moved opposite directions
nepal you know got uh a new wind you
know tailwind and and and fabi basically
got a headwind
what do you feel about the quality of
play in this particular candidates we've
seen that kramnik in the first few
rounds he was very critical of the
quality that he saw from the players of
course there's a lot of different
scenarios tensions openings also have to
influence but what is your personal take
about the general play of this year
look i i wouldn't be so critical yeah i
mean you can always
you know point out that mistakes now
it's easy because we have computers and
you can easily point out a mistake
mistake mistake i wouldn't i wouldn't uh
i'll be so harsh on them i think there's
a day they have been you know they've
been working really hard all the players
you know and coming up with new ideas so
it's this this uh you could see that the
tournament you know definitely just you
know shows us that even in the famous
openings you know you can come up with
some ideas i mean for instance caruanas
yesterday that okay it's a horrible game
he lost a game that he could have won
probably under different conditions but
you know just you know bringing his
knight on g7 and then playing h3 i mean
that's interesting you know so it's the
again
for me this is this is a it's a good
tournament because it demonstrates that
they all have been doing their homework
so you look at every player and you know
even talia rizzo is just not you know
having a
great experience he also tried hard to
to come up with with a couple of new
ideas and
and i think just if we if we try to
value the contribution of the tournament
to to modern church yeah i wouldn't be
so so critical as chronic
and that is something that we love
seeing from the candidates speaking of
that player ali reza
he had an interesting way of trying to
get rid of tilt he loses this game
against hikaru nakamura famously goes on
a binge 250 games played online that
night 250 games of chess have you ever
done that where you felt that you lost
the game and the only way to come back
mentally was to grab somebody in a blitz
match and just beat them up
yeah that's um yeah i think they're
playing uh uh
playing bullet chess um
it's not a good idea period
if you prepare for the candidate playing
it during the tournament is is is
um
even much worse
and playing it after a loss uh trying to
sort of to
i don't recover your uh
uh pride your honor and that's too too
to to massage your ego
it's it's triple bad
so and and it's not surprising i didn't
know about it but i i think that's
that's that's
probably you know the the way nepal
crushed him next day
was probably the case's cases uh uh um
bringing you up just cannot do that yeah
he's played 250 games up to 6am online
against daniel dardisky kind of explains
his play the next day right g4 h4 total
bullet just
exactly but that's a problem you know
that's the it's i look i think what's
happened with him again i'm i'm not
privy to his preparation but i thought
he could do much much better but i think
you know he he
radically overestimated his chances it's
the somehow it reminds me of bobby
fischer in 1962 in in curacao though i
would say fisher in 1962 was
i would say
looking at the at the ranking was
probably you know um
higher than that and than perugia uh uh
uh today uh again it's very it's it's
very subjective but again fish already
won the intro zonal and you already
played one candidates three years
earlier but after his
uh victory in stockholm he came to
curacao believing that time for him just
to crush all the soviets yeah of course
he complained that they made draws they
didn't play against each other but he
was young enough you know and if he was
as good as in 1972 nobody would have
stopped
but he he didn't perform up to his
expectations and i think ali reza went
to madrid thinking that oh it's time for
me i just you know i could uh crush all
these old guys all by his standards
and uh and i think he just didn't
realize that it's candidates it's very
different from the tournament he won yes
he won a very good tournament but even
in this tournament he lost to caruana to
a really strong opponent that he had
and uh and uh it's a it's clear that his
uh his preparation and his class
is not nearly enough to to um win the
tournament or even just to be to be
competitive uh there's tons of work to
be done and again i hope that
he will realize you know that's that's
this this work is to be done and and he
will do a better work than you know
playing uh playing more bullet chess
gary uh my co-host uh dorsa
has a question she's uh been
prying to dying to ask you doris
well first of all thank you thank you so
much for being here i'm very honored to
be talking to you you're such a legends
like i've just grown up watching yeah
he's used to that he's used to that
no you're not getting an autograph get
out of here
but i do have
well two questions one of them is a
little chest related one of them is not
translated at all uh do you have a pick
would you like a chess one first or a
non-chess one
uh it's it's yeah i'm i'll answer
he's ready he's ready all right let me
start with a fun one
any favorite vacation spots
favorite vacation spots
um
yeah
since i spent every summer since 1993
croatia well i think it's the answer is
is is is is natural so
if you talk about summer locations
absolutely croatia it just reminds me
the place i was born back in buckwheat
and so same climate so as for cities to
visit it's a long list of many beautiful
cities uh mostly in europe because i i
traveled extensively across europe and
and i'm i'm i'm
i'm afraid to make to make to put them
in in just you know in in certain
ranking because it's um you know things
change but i get i love traveling across
europe visiting old cities and enjoying
you know that's the
the great history ancient history behind
the walls yeah well wonderful thank you
and the other question was that a few
years ago you had the winter's coming
book such a wonderful book and you've
given so many interviews about it since
then as well any upcoming book
yes yes i i think that you know by by my
60s i will have a new book that will be
somehow a combination of um
uh three previous non-chess books how i
feel with hs was 2007. winter is coming
you mentioned
released in 2015 and deep thinking in
2017
so it's about decision making it's about
geopolitics and it's about uh human
machine relations collaboration
um the tentative title of the book is
the world of fake values but uh it's
probably will be titled for the for for
introduction i'm not sure about the
final title but it's about um
it's about the current state of affairs
of um
of humanity so how we got there to the
point where we are talking about the
worst war since uh 1945
and so what's next and why certain
things are connected so i'm trying to
make connections between um
economic affairs political affairs
social affairs tech technology and
trying to come up with with my vision of
the big picture
sounds uh exciting if that leaves it to
me
to ask you a chess question gary i want
to draw your attention to the game
between duda and farrugia
after the move g2 g3 remarkably enough
gary the players are actually still in
theory at this point in all of the games
that are yeah
all of the games
all of the games
all of the games in our database up to
this moment
have continued as follows uh pardon me
has
have continued
c6 c5 but c5 c5 would be very natural
and to put the bishop on d4
and that's the most
everybody who ever reached this position
as black has always played c5
farouza came up
with the extraordinary movement yes yes
i'm looking at the at the clock so now
on on the screen so do you think that
seruga
knew it was opening i think that either
side knew what they were doing because
there were tons of games reaching they
spent too much time right right
yeah it's sort of like they kind of
sleep walk their way into this position
and they would spend 10 minutes and then
play the theoretically recommended move
like for example uh in this position
uh it's not obvious that you would want
to play the move queen e7 but after some
time alireza found that move and he
found queen c7 and again they go down
this theoretical path that neither one
of them were aware that they were
walking and instead of playing the move
c5 came this move g5
which blew me away
well again this is let can we come back
to what alex alejandro said about you
know bull chest
g5 and you remember what he played
yesterday yes g4 h4 g5 it's the same say
same story why'd you play g5 why do you
open your king c5 bishop d4 that's
that's what you should do and i i don't
i i don't know the evaluation it seems
to me black probably should hold right
again i i never seen the position before
but i can hardly imagine that with palm
on b2 and bishop on d4 protecting by the
pawn and black king is
sufficiently um covered by pawns that
was pawn on g7
so i i
yeah i i would say that black shoot
should not should not uh
be worse again i don't know maybe maybe
white has some sort of i don't know the
c5
f4 bishop d4 check
it looks to me that
i don't know i don't know what computer
says it says zero and it's been known as
zero there's a lot of draws at the top
level of grand masters yeah well that
says again that's that's that's what
okay the only thing you don't have to
play knight d7 to do to do to blunt the
rook takes d4 but otherwise you know yes
here bishop d4 english don't play knight
decent rook takes d4 that's the only
thing you should avoid
yeah this is yeah yes but but uh but
otherwise i think it's this is it's look
to me natural i mean
i wouldn't have even i mean i would
consider g5 but but i would not have
played that because now it's you know
you have it's an extra exchange and uh
and
it's very good it's it's a it's a very
um
um
rapid chess arabic blitz even even blue
chests
so um by the way i don't know what's
next what's next here so um what what
you what you weren't told is that ali
reza played these
250 bullet games till six o'clock in the
morning
against the official commentator
donya naraditsky
so you agree with me that it's
irresponsible of dania as official
commentator
he'll play till six o'clock in the
morning
oh by the way
there's two two two to go to the bottom
of the story who has won
oh
[Laughter]
the best commentaries
wow
um you have always been
connected associated very strongly with
michael bauvinick who was supposedly we
don't know this a stern
teacher what would budvinic have said
about
hakaru streaming
streaming during the candidates
tournament after each and every round
he's been streaming on his channel
you know it's an interesting question i
mean as you know um as for playing you
know blitz uh we didn't have of course
bullet at a time so online but still you
know between was was very
uh negative on any any any form of blitz
rapid chess
and and of course you know just doing it
during the tournament would be would be
an asthma to him
now as for streaming i'm curious because
yeah it's doing this kind of you know
outside business um during the
tournament that's bad but but finnick
was very um
uh complementary for just the players
who tried to analyze their games i don't
know how much chicago is analyzing them
but but it might be some sort of um
you know could could be a form of
indulgence for icarus eyes
because he was doing something something
good for explaining how he played so
it's descend again i don't think it
would exonerate him completely but you
know yes it's it's again there was a
chance for indulgence
fair fair okay again gary i'm gonna draw
your game uh to uh ding lyrin versus
timor don't do that i just do other
stuff
don't do that too
this is so over
this is so over he did play knight d1 oh
my gosh
i i asked alejandro gary i said come on
uh alejandro tell me what ding's best
option in this moment after rook takes
e3 king takes e3 he's losing of course
he said knight d1 i said stop it i i
don't even want to look if that's the
best it's terrible he played knight d1
knight e3
and they've reached this position as you
were about to say they're still playing
it looks like
they are still still playing yes
um
okay so
yeah
i don't know it's um it should be
lost of course of course
you know after after um what's happening
in ding's game yesterday
you know when he just you know
he survived and then won you know i uh i
i actually i saw them that you just i i
watched the game you know just uh it's
uh coming back and forth to the screen
so i saw this opening who's not just
saying also very interesting so when he
played b3 and this is this is it's very
very uh sharp position and then i saw
position after knight e6 and then f4 i
was surprised he takes a four i wouldn't
have done that so and then i saw the the
opposite color bishops and he played d4
and i saw what maybe he could sort of
survive and then i left you know his
kids you know went to the beach and then
he came back and said wow what's
happened this is end game and it's lost
end game what how he how
fabi could have lost his po
what's happening
i couldn't figure out how he could lose
yeah and then i just look at the game
and say wow that's uh
as ding was lucky but you know he's he's
stubborn and um
okay let's go back to the game but this
is it's curious so the states it's of
course it's it's it's lost but it's um
yeah
it's team curious yeah so what's the
what's the machine's best option here
knight takes you four the machine's best
option is knight h5 with minus nine all
the secondary best moves
look that's what i think if unless he
plays knight h5 the game yeah knight h5
that's it yeah because bishop just read
and that's that's it everything's
paralyzed right so let's see if you want
to calculate a little bit more rookie 2
followed by bishop f4 forces white to
give up the queen
no it's the
you know uh
you know in this kind of position you
know uh
my it's late yuri on would have said you
know if you take away bishop from d7
maybe position will be unclear
you had some fun with yuri
yeah this is that's that's that's
his reaction so this is yeah but but but
and last night i think he played knight
h5 i think the game might might take
longer so okay
i'm curious if he finds it because he if
he finds it you know then you should say
that rajab uh played a very important
role in in securing nepal's victory
because he beat hikaru
when hikaru thought he was on the rise
right and then and then now he's if he's
now stops ding you know
that's
that's quite an accomplishment uh gary
we want to thank you very much for
having joined us but i'd also
do want you to get in a last word if you
don't mind
uh we consider nepo's victory has just
assured
should
he play
a rematch with magnus should magnus
accept
and play the match
your thoughts about a second
nepo versus magnus
match will it be a better match
look
um i still think madness is a clear
favorite in the match but
i think somehow neville might have a
better psychological um
start
because he already played magnus and
magnus will be definitely i mean we know
magnus is
not tired but it's
i think he's bored too many matches and
seeing nepo again might uh
lower his um enthusiasm for preparation
and for playing um
so if history
is any he is offering us any guidance
so magnus played two matches with vichy
but again that's that was the beginning
of magnus reigns
he was you know it's much fresher and
and he still believe he had to prove
that he was the best but do you remember
the second match you know it's again
game six this is magical yeah he was you
know he was one move away from losing
and that could be a very different match
exactly so um
and also by the way let's not forget you
know if we look at history vasily
smithslaw was the only one who won two
candidates in the row in 53 and 56
and after winning the second the second
match he beat batwinnick in his 1950s in
world championship match again it's an
ancient history but still
so winning second match second candidate
especially in this style that that we
saw in madrid so definitely make
snapweights in my view a very formidable
opponent for magnus
no matter you know what magnus thinks
about it and uh and if mangos plays and
i i can hardly believe he will not
so um then we'll see probably a tougher
match and
and it seems that nepo is is getting
more
resilient so it's the
is
more stable
and um i guess this match probably
taught him you know some very important
lessons
uh yes some say oh he was lucky here he
was lucky with hikaru he was like it was
karana he was lucky maybe it was ding in
the first round who could have thought
that would be so in such an important
game round one of the tournament
uh but um you know it's
yes if you're so lucky that means you
know you are you are
really a winner so because this this
only winner can accumulate so much luck
gary thank you so much for your wise
words your insights it's always a
pleasure to see you thank you thank you
and thank you okay keep watching all
right promise thank you very much bye
bye gary kasparov everybody